always
[Music]
you're voting against
so you do
you're on top and now you're lifting
your hand well that's always weight and
so what you usually see it people say
kicked about this far or they get up
there takes a lot of muscle and then it
starts to pull it down so watch what she
died
when the moms go you see where it is
he's now not below the sea and Jota is
now pushing him up not pulling him up if
you're feeling like get it up there
being pulled down you were short under
shriyak boom they're just right there
then you can come up
so it's like a
and when you see that long
I just wanted to don't I don't care how
you do it and I want you to display so
you must take this fine line and take
over that territory here my question is
through hold as much like in principle
as you can so I always have mid-foot
wait don't get on your heels that's not
hard
and then you just are displacing as a
unit that's all you're doing just
displace in the Union
so and we're just one class mid-foot
didn't shove anything it it's just in my
mind right I'm down going like this
right
usually you've sparred you've learned
aggression like here beginner level
stuff
just practice psychology of aggression
okay it's a very simple fix
like where's his shikaku it's so be
there
Thanks
[Music]
but you're
because I Center
[Music]
the analogy of the Russian stacking
dolls
so you guys all know those dolls you
open it up when there's one more exactly
like that so it's hard to call it
Chinese because that meant something
different when this thinking was being
developed generally Claude East Asian
but in traditions that we now call
Chinese such as that was Yong Yong Yong
theory you had this concept of microcosm
and macrocosm so it's true here and
therefore can be true at larger levels
we have a sign somewhere in here which
is a which says so above so below that's
that same concept if you read musashi's
book of five rings he tells you the way
of fighting 100 men
limbs become like our knees get it
battalions like the same way
concentric tweet so when you have these
are movements right you're looking at
generally an inward turning spiral and
then you can reverse these things so you
have an outlet when spiral and then you
will have three Heights Joe Don - Don
get on but it is the same either the
inward turning spiral or to our
attorneys buzzer you get it and this is
not one of them okay this has become one
of them because we're not paying
attention but it's not what we're doing
here so if I want to lift my arm
it will be lifted on that spiral or this
because this is week this is week even
if I get physically strong eventually I
get old and I can't do it so you have a
lot of strong people when they start
hitting their 50s 60s 70s and it not so
strong anymore because these muscles get
weaker with age and with injury which
that's prone to injury so I move my hand
always that's what I want to do is in
these spiders ok well that could also be
looked at as at a kind of level of
analogy so for example I go this is a
manifestation of my of my proper body
movement well what is that body movement
doing well I don't want to lift in a
straight way I don't want to use small
muscle groups I don't want to employ a
system that is very time sensitive now
you have all the more of a life
philosophy you could do that ok so for
example let's take this little drill and
let's look at it strategically ok if I
go around the first
and they are side by side with me get it
however I really established dominance
tactically no we're just we're 50/50
again you're on that side on this side
so if they have a weapon and I have a
weapon that's not a good place to be to
put someone behind my back in equal
amount so but if they're just going to
hold on to my wrist then it would work
you see that so it's working under a
very small situation not now we're not
following that other let's not have such
limiting applications let's see if we
can have a universal application so for
so then you can stick a weapon in the
other guy's hand and it will not change
this dynamics we could take the weapon
out of that person stand it will not
change the dynamics you can have another
person coming in it will not change the
dynamics yes one application is able to
answer many many more situations so that
is nothing more than another Russian
doll of the same physiological and that
is what you're supposed to do so I
mentioned we Sachi and we actually
talked about the sword is cannot be
thought of as a trivial thing because
always are in the sword he can say that
because he's employing this east-asian
way of thinking he is using that sword
as a Russian doll for these other truths
so then he can inversely say this is all
those other dolls you hear this today
where a lot of people
everything's jiu-jitsu right it's
because they're able to see and apply
right what is the principle of
non-resistance it's in the art right
what is the principle of leverage it's
in the art what is the principle of
communion and then removing sin the more
so you can start using those as and
you're supposed to as life philosophies
okay but do not get confused with the
modern way of this here's my caveat they
can be used as life philosophies but the
ultimate aim of Budo is not a life
philosophy it is a way of being so if
what I'm trying to do remains is the
philosophy and it's not innately in me
then I'm not doing my Buddha which means
that when my boss comes and gets on me
and it takes two days for me to
reconcile that energy and harmonize with
it then this is just an intellectual
exercise
it's got to be medium as immediate as
you grab me go you come in you're the
boss you're yelling at me it's
triggering me boom I feel it attempt on
right I'm not there anymore we're not in
contention
I'm not suffering inside and we get all
this why
same thing goes not just my boss it's
gonna be the same thing with my parents
or my spouse's do you get it because we
might want to go no when I'm at home I'm
not going to do the art I'm gonna be a
little dog Emperor to get it and your
art is now just intellectual which is
why we practice it if we just wanted a
philosophy we could just have a
university class any other technical
questions on the technique
not even on no comments
[Music]
so let's think about two ways of doing
this ten yeah I enter the person is
basically still upright and then not
used to have to now bring them into a
descending or I enter in such a way that
they're already followed and I'm now
lowering the hand on a descending body
which one takes less energy the second
one
so therefore which one will have a
higher mechanical ceiling meaning which
one will I be able to do on a bigger
person the second one so if you guess
this is why I was trying to have you
make it one and I was telling you you're
ensuring is what's taking their balance
they're already following it is much
more energy efficient to aim falling
people than to throw people down okay
throwing people down takes a lot of
energy if you're aiming falling people
you can actually leave them in the
descent and get to your weapon
but if they're still standing and are
waiting for you to do that
you are as occupied as they are so maybe
not physically you're not being pinned
but you are strategically tactically and
therefore ideational ease as much
trapped in that as they are okay when
your body enters to displace they're
already falling you can opt to leave
them there just let go and you can go to
your weapon you can get
yeah you only get to that part and then
the arms underneath and then therefore
yeah a little bit so usually what
happens is I think we had like different
training cultures because we do the one
where in other cultures you're expected
to go to the side and you do kind of go
more around you use the distal and
lovely theory do you know what I mean so
when you do this you you
mechanical engine that I will work on
that perimeter forearm to get this to me
but we're doing something different you
see how we're going like this and so
that each cable do something else it's
just why I kept saying keep your breath
keep it right because when you when you
take your when you allow that little bit
of movement ok has a lot more leeway and
what they can do or not do so ok keeps
their grip
they get where they need to be but what
still happens especially when you are
not using your individual muscle groups
your arm is very relaxed it is very
difficult for that you get to who is
basically intellectualizing where to go
to know where to go so what usually
happens if you have the right ankle is
they won't go to the side is they can't
hold on at all and you have just entered
into do you understand that
but then Paco was able to so you you
it's a mixture of both he had a
different training culture with that
thrill and you were not entering
straightaway enough is what we should
have seen which is a very important
tactic we were doing that in weapons to
the other day with a kick so the guy
came in we threw a kick and as he's
falling backwards from you know from the
blow not falling but moving boom we came
in so Michael had a call where he got
charged
after this person was threatening
convenience store employee he got
charged he did the kid the guy went
backwards and there was too much delay
for my biking because there's an opening
you see if the guy is going backwards
oh that's the if you have the initiative
but if you lemonhope backwards in these
stops now you have to regain English
okay so look you if you enter into the
body and he lets go you will still have
the initiative to go to something else
if you're going around the body any
let's go you had there was no initiative
okay so we're choosing to go in
tactically weight conditioning wise
there's more resistance because there's
more matter that you're trying to
displace so it's a better conditioning
exercise
oops
and that's how you learn you know I I
have have I don't think the system is
really work I think what a good teacher
should do is try to give you multiple
opportunities to find it and the best
way of doing it is to have drills we're
doing it wrong becomes painfully obvious
but it doesn't automatically guarantee
that you will gain the awareness right
you kind of kind of have to stumble
across it I think it's very much akin to
where the first person may be maybe how
their child learns language right I mean
when you point when you point to this
and you
you have to figure out if I mean color I
mean the cover I mean the density do I
mean the whole thing does that from the
other side of the line also mean back
and you have to keep hanging out and you
start to feel and sense and experience
notice is this that's the same as this
as this whole thing you see so maybe
you're a kid and you thought I meant
green and then you went over there and
you go Matt and I gotta go no that's
brown not math we do that I believe that
is what's happening and I believe that
is why the sensei dashi relationship is
so important you can't learn it in books
and what happened what we have seen
instead is that people are not very
interested in the right
we won't have teachers
and teach maybe no technical issues is a
technical distinction all right